[Music]
this is festival foodies where we go to
fairs across the country and try three
things a fan favorite a hidden gem and a
wacky snack then we pick our favorites
this week we're at the Big E let's dig
in Raj and I'm Ali and this is festival
foodies today we're at the biggie the
biggie is New England's greatest fair
where all six states come together to
celebrate their heritage and of course
their food ready to do it let's go go
first up is the fan favorite everyone
knows about the cream puffs and the
Eclair is at the biggie it's the number
one stop at the fair so let's hit this
boot in the early 2000s the fair decided
to make the biggie cream puff the iconic
dessert of the biggie everything's made
on-site in the bakery so on a daily
basis they're constantly baking all day
long out back there prepping creams
stuffing shelves frosting eclairs so on
a daily basis that people can not only
enjoy them but they can watch them being
made on a typical day will sell about
2,500 to 3,000 eclairs and approximately
5,000 cream puffs and so really if you
want to enjoy it as thousands and
thousands of people do it's the only
chance to get them so how did you guys
hear about the biggie cream pie no I
tried this years ago
I look forward to it every year oh my
god these look incredible or can we dive
in here oh let's dive in okay
that crow bugs are really good that
cream is super sweet and then mixed with
this like popover sandwich oh my
goodness I could eat this entire thing
look how much cream is on here they are
generous at this fair age a lucky for
you I'm willing to share well I
appreciate that Cheers
[Music]
next it's time for a hidden gem freedos
is a staple here in Springfield and
they're known for their one pound
meatball let's eat
my name is Joel freed I'm third
generation here at the store my
grandfather started the business here in
Springfield in 1950 he was a cheese
maker it came from the northern part of
Italy small town called Asiago one day
we were fooling around and created this
one pound meatball well I always say you
can't beat a homemade meatball and I'm
sure our meatballs are not gonna compare
to your mom's meatballs but this is our
family recipe where we're using all
fresh ingredients and we love to see the
repeat customers come back year to year
at the big eats it's very gratifying
what made you get this today start from
the area and everybody
are you gonna finish this whole thing
you think that's really good
mmm the meats like super tender and
juicy it is very flavorful yeah I
wouldn't expect to get this kind of
bloody ball at a fair yeah no I feel
like I'm in Italy right now or at an
authentic Italian restaurant yes it's
tender its juicy its flavorful I mean
you can really taste that this is a
family recipe yeah a generation yes that
someone really cares about the quality
of the food
[Music]
this one bad meatball is pretty wacky
but not as wacky as our wacky snack oh
boy
last but not least our wacky snack are
you ready for a sweet treat I'm always
ready for a sweet treat well this place
has chocolate dipped bananas with
colorful top oh that sounds good it's
calling my name well chuckle cover
banana has been around forever and I
thought well why not cuz you would take
off something different you can pretty
much customize your banana any way you'd
like cherries we raspberry the white
chocolate chocolate peanut butter and
then we have the variety of toppings
Oreo and chocolate rainbow sprinkles and
all various colors well I think people
know chocolate-covered bananas from your
childhood and I think younger people
with young children think that this is a
healthier option for their children
I need more followers on Instagram and
this is the way to get it but it's tiny
seeds like banana flavor days taste like
cotton candy
[Music]
this is definitely the most Instagram
Abul thing we've seen all day I love the
colors and how vibrant these bananas are
and it's a banana so technically it's
healthy yeah I think these are healthy I
really like the way that the blue
raspberry pears what's that frozen
banana okay I am dying to try this
chocolate peanut butter one there's no
better combination on this planet than
peanut butter and bananas frozen banana
is the healthy ice cream we didn't know
we needed it tastes just as good if not
better because it's covered in chocolate
and peanut butter
[Music]
AJ we ate a lot today that we Bowl is
your favorite thing uh it's tough to
make but I'm probably gonna have to go
with the cream puffs I love that sweet
Center and then the puff pastry on top
and then there's nothing better than
when you use like eat it like a sandwich
and it all comes out it's messy but it's
fun and it's delicious what about you AJ
what was your top pick oh man of all the
things we ate today I gotta give it to
the Johnny meatball
it was just so good it was so flavorful
and honestly I kind of accidentally ate
the whole thing
accidentally you would even in a second
if I would have given you mine I really
would have we give the biggie a very a
plus we'll see you at the next one
stay hungry
[Music]
you